six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the
three-30 area code caller from three
three zero
who's this where you're calling from hey
David my name is Estlin I'm calling from
Keene Ohio it's like you are simply
London great what's what's on your mind
today so I was just wondering I haven't
seen a lot of debate on this topic
actually other than sort of them in some
niche at parts of Twitter but what I'm
sort of wondering is do you believe that
a religion or any organization really
that identifies with a race like they're
a race based religion or race based
organisation do you believe that
organizations like that are inherently
racist if they believe that that's
somehow that there's somehow a
Brotherhood and that so let me see if I
understand if there was a religion like
for example I don't know not
Christianity but we'll call it like I
don't know black Christianity where only
black Christians are allowed in or or
like when you say that the group is
exclusionary are you talking about in
the legal sense or are you saying that
as as a as a sort of self because
because I think you would run into
problems very quickly if you say
literally you can't be here unless
you're of a certain race but you're
saying a face is sin I get the more
that's how they see themselves I guess
some more like a better example
something that you can relate to a
little more with arc with the context of
art culture yeah let's just say for
example in Scripture it says that the
Jewish and the Jewish races the Jewish
people are chosen people you people a
statement like that should be something
that we consider inherently racist and
like choose a society to not tolerate or
do you think that statements like that
are okay within the context of religion
or any organization really I I'm against
I don't believe in any of those comments
and I'm against them the idea that Jews
are the people chosen by God or that the
black Israelites are actually the real
Jews or that the Mormon Church doesn't
see black people or didn't used to see
black people as full people like I'm
against all of that I don't think any of
it is legitimate but I guess I'm unsure
whether you're asking me whether legally
it should be okay for a religion to say
that
mm-hmm um no not particularly I met more
is to what extent should we tolerate
identity organizations as a society in
terms of just like tolerating rather
than like legally prohibiting is there
something else and there's a reason I'm
asking this is there something else
you're sort of getting at with the
question because it's it's big you've
you've brought in the question so much -
should we tolerate identity
organizations and with identity politics
being such a touchy topic I'm wondering
if there's something underneath this
that you're sort of trying to get to I
guess a larger question would mostly
just be are like race based
organizations and apparently races like
if there's any sort of inherent racism
in that or if it depends from a case to
case basis I think it I think it does
depend I think that there there are
membership organizations or not
membership organizations affinity
organizations like is there anything
inherently racist about a black student
union or an LGBT Student Union and a
college not inherently because they're
not necessarily looking to subjugate
others they're creating a meeting point
for people who are part of a certain
group so it's not inherently racist the
problem is that very often those types
of groups in practice become
discriminatory and I think that's what
we have to really have a problem with so
another question I would have is if you
had the reverse side of that so if you
had an organization that was like for
example like I said if you have
scripture that says that Jewish people
are the chosen religion or the chosen
race and the followers of that religion
don't believe that but the religion
itself works you have you know at some
points that that um is the religion
itself rather than the followers
something that is inherently wrong in
our society and should we tolerate
people who prescribe to that religion
even if they don't necessarily believe
that part of that religion III think
that the question is a total non-starter
I mean basically what you're saying is
if you can find a
legend that now or at any point had an
unsavory belief should you condemn every
single person who says they are a
follower regardless of whether they even
subscribe to that particular belief I
mean it's just you're not gonna get
anywhere with that right like so so
basically what I I just don't see the
practicality of that at all well I mean
I I'm more like should we do we have
like an obligation to if somebody
follows something they don't really to
full-scale understand its purpose should
we I'll if if the followers of something
shaped the beliefs of an organization
should we then tolerate that
organization or maybe you said the
followers look at subscribers or
followers don't subscribe to the crazy
belief anyway so so Alyssa I I got a run
there's something here you're trying to
get to that you're not really getting to
and maybe someday we'll figure out what
it is but I'm just not sure it's a lot
of circular questions that that I'm
hearing there